[Musique]
en famille seul ou entre amis sportifs
culturel nature ludique à sensation ou
insolite il existe des activités pour
tous les âgés pour tous les goûts à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines au plus de la
moitié du territoire et constituer
l'espace vert et bleu
des espaces à l'image de l'île de
loisirs par exemple la sur 600 hectares
de nature vous pourrez profiter d'une
foultitude d'animation tout l'été kayak
voit l'équitation golf Rosalie Segway
vélo découverte animalières à la ferme
pédagogique barbecue nuit et ses jours
sous tipi malade énigme il se passe
toujours quelque chose dans cette île de
loisirs qui est la seule à avoir une
réserve naturelle nationale classée
Natura 2000 et qui est la plus grande
d'Île-de-France le projet de l'île de
loisirs c'est vraiment d'être ouvert un
large public large public
56 mois d'abord il faut qu'on privilégie
tous les habitants de Saint-Quentin mais
bien de bien au-delà sur le département
des Yvelines l'accessibilité donc nous
avons maintenant un nouvel accueil avec
des fils d'accès qui ont été multipliés
par 4 donc maintenant nous avons quatre
fils d'accès une qui sera plus dédiée
particulièrement au golfeur qui sont
puisque on a à peu près sur une année 66
000 entrées de golfeurs par rapport à
200 000 200 000 entrées de voitures il
faut savoir qu'il y a à peu près 700 000
personnes 700 000 personnes c'est un
chiffre considérable qui entre dans la
Base de Loisirs soit en voiture mais
bien sûr également à pied en vélo c'est
le plus grand nombre d'entrée sur un
site après le château de Versailles mais
ça prouve que l'île de loisirs a une
attractivité
importante pour tous les 50 chinois sur
ces entrées à peu près 50% sont des 50
chinois pour l'instant on est toujours
sur des entrées gratuites voitures le
système va changer à partir du mois
d'octobre puisque nous aurons trois
entrées gratuites pour les 56 mois et un
abonnement
à 20 euros le tarif normal d'une
entreprise payante c'est 4 euros 20 et
avec l'abonnement ça sera donc 2 euros
10 et cet été vous ferez le plein
d'activités avec encore plus de
nouveautés et un villageoisir du 84
entre juillet un village sportif du 27
juillet au 28 août un judo tour du 19 au
21 juillet et encore plein plein
d'autres activités tout ce qui touche
l'animation sportive il y aura le
village d'été et puis nous créons des
nouvelles activités comme le ventrique
tout type d'activités qui vont se
tourner autour du sable le beach volley
et autres et puis un bubble bubble foot
qui est donc des personnes qui sont dans
des grandes bulles qui vont s'amuser à
se cogner les unes aux autres
[Musique]
et ceux qui aiment les sensations ne
manqueront pas de faire un tour à
brancher loisir pour profiter de leur
parcours aventure dans les arbres
le parcours aventure de l'île de loisirs
donc c'est déjà le seul parcours
aventure du 78 donc c'est un parcours
qui se situe effectivement sur l'île de
loisirs de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un parcours
bassin du coup c'est un endroit où dans
les arbres vous allez trouver des
activités suspendues d'arbres en arbre
et qui permettent du coup d'évoluer en
toute sécurité en pleine hauteur et
surtout en pleine nature on a du coup un
parc pour les enfants de 3 à 6 ans du
coup il va être 100 baudrier avec un
grand filet pour la protection
collective
dès 6 ans les enfants ont accès aux
baudrier et à deux niveaux à 3 mètres
puis à 7 mètres et pour les plus de 12
ans ça monte à 12 et à 15 mètres
sur les hits ici on va trouver pas mal
de petites choses on a du coup sur le
parcours bleu une vague donc qui vous
permet du coup de monter et descendre
tout en tout en s'élevant en hauteur on
va avoir du coinceau Tarzan qui va
permettre du coup de se faire un saut à
6 mètres de hauteur on va voir en vélo
donc vous permettre du coup de pédaler
directement à 8 mètres de hauteur
et pour accroître encore un peu plus les
sensations ne manquez surtout pas
l'acronight estivale qui se déroulera le
28 août le principe d'une acronyme du
coup c'est de réaliser du coup un
parcours acrobatique en hauteur mais
cette fois-ci le faire deux jours de le
faire de nuit donc du coup ici on a pris
le concept de prendre un côté fluo pour
apporter un petit peu de fun à la fun à
l'événement donc du coup on installe des
spots ultraviolets dans les arbres on
vous propose un maquillage fluo en début
d'activité et vous partez du coup équipé
d'une lampe frontale pour quand même
voir où vous allez et vous évoluer du
coup dans le noir sur les parcours
[Musique]
de multiples activités à l'île de
loisirs donc mais cet été vous ne
manquerez pas non plus les désormais
traditionnels plages cinq continents à
Montigny du 4 juillet au 23 août et à
Trappes du 6 juillet au 8 août au menu
des activités pour tous du sport des
jeux de plage de la zumba des spectacles
et des animations en pagaille et si vous
êtes plutôt terrasse sachez que l'équipe
de la médiathèque des 7 mars vous
attendra deux pieds ferme une grande
partie de l'été alors la terrasse aura
lieu du 7 juillet au 31 août tous les
mardis et tous les vendredis à la
médiathèque des 7 Mares de 15h à 17h
sauf pendant la première quinzaine
d'août le principe de la terrasse c'est
donc l'installation de transat et d'une
tonnelle devant la médiathèque à
l'extérieur et nous proposons au
lecteurs et à toutes les personnes qui
qui souhaitent s'installer qui passent
par là de s'installer sur les transats
et de prendre un moment de détente de
lire de feuilleter des magazines et on
aura le mariage pour les enfants des
déçus docus des mots croisés ce sera
pendant des créneaux ou la médiathèque
est fermée ou publique et on propose à
la place un service en extérieur le but
c'était de proposer un service même
quand nous étions fermés par ailleurs
sachez que même si le réseau passe à
l'heure d'été en juillet août avec des
horaires modifiés et des fermetures
saisonnières d'équipement vous trouverez
toujours une médiathèque ouverte à
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines à l'image du
petit canal qui accueille le public
pendant les travaux réalisés à la
médiathèque du canal et qui restera
ouverte tous les thés
et s'il y a un événement à ne pas
manquer cet été c'est bien le
Paris-Brest Paris qui se déroule
rappelons-le tous les quatre ans la 18e
édition de la plus grande rando
cyclotouriste du monde partira en effet
de 50 ans nuvelines le 16 août avec
cette année un départ qui se fera depuis
le vélodrome l'occasion de croiser des
cycles touristes venus du monde entier
sur des montures parfois improbables
pour mémoire le Paris-Brest Paris c'est
plus de 5300 participants 56
nationalités représentées et 1200 km à
parcourir un événement aime surtout pas
manquer et qui prouve une fois de plus
que 50 ans en Yvelines qui a déjà
accueilli les mondiaux de cyclisme en
mars et bel et bien la capitale du vélo
il faut dire qu'avec plus de 85 km de
pistes cyclables et des espaces verts et
bleu qui occupent plus de 62% du
territoire les cyclistes sont ici de
quoi trouver leur bonheur pour en
profiter pleinement cet été sachez
qu'une carte détaillée des pistes
cyclables de l'agneau est disponible à
l'agence de la mobilité située à la gare
de Saint-Quentin mais aussi à l'accueil
de l'hôtel d'agglomération dans les
mairies des sept communes à l'accueil de
l'île de loisirs vous pouvez également
la télécharger sur le site à l'écran
et pour découvrir le territoire seul en
groupe en famille ou entre amis de
manière ludique et originale vous pouvez
aussi télécharger des réalités
thématiques concoctées par le musée de
la ville c'est des rallye patrimoine art
et nature en règle générale donc il y a
trois parcours de longueur différentes 8
km à 13 km dans des lieux différents de
l'agglomération sachant que vous passez
toujours dans des endroits plutôt
sympathiques plutôt dans les centres un
peu les chemins de traverse et donc vous
découvrez des lieux que vous voyez pas
quand vous allez d'un point à un point B
il y a trois thèmes il y en a un qui est
sur l'art dans la ville qui est le plus
court qui est dans le quartier
Saint-Quentin et au niveau du parc des
sources de la Bièvre donc un peu entre
ville et nature autour des œuvres d'art
qui ponctuent le chemin il y en a 8 il y
en a qui est sur le thème Promenons-nous
dans les années 70 qui se passent sur
Élancourt entre le quartier des 7 Mares
et le parc des Coudrais donc qui est
vraiment sur la thématique seventies
avec à la fois le l'urbain le parc et
également des petits rappels de ce qui
se passait dans les années 70
et le dernier qui est vraiment
patrimoine à rien nature qui est le plus
long qui fait 13 km qui part également
du quartier Saint-Quentin et qui
s'enfonce vers ce qu'on appelle les
trois villages donc on va vers la source
de riz à travers le parc des sources de
la Bièvre donc c'est un c'est un rallye
particulièrement ouvert où on prend
beaucoup de sens
ainsi s'achève notre dossier et sachez
que vous pouvez retrouver encore plein
d'autres propositions olski mag de
juillet août ainsi que sur le site du
kiosque qui a recensé pour vous toutes
les activités de l'été alors bon été à
tous et à bientôt
[Musique]